foreign
my whole life I'm originally from
Memphis from a neighborhood called Bing
Hampton here went to Elementary in the
City High School the East High School
played basketball did all this stuff so
I'm met her all my life and my mom had
me when she was like 15. and she did a
great job actually because I went to
college I went to trade school I steered
away from all that all the uh bad stuff
that was going on the drug selling the
gangs I steered clear that my whole life
but when I got into a situation and lost
the job
it was the only thing that had to fall
back on was the neighborhood so once I
went back to the neighborhood that was
pretty much the only thing that was
going on over there me not having a
father I didn't have anybody to lean on
once I lost my job I had nobody to talk
to so I started talking to the guys that
I grew up with and it was easy for me to
fall into the same road that they was um
one thing led to another and we got in
trouble
Distributing cocaine
I got caught uh Distributing we met with
a intent to sell and I did five years in
federal prison
so
I think if I would have had a father I
would have had somebody that I could
talk to about it kind of steering me
stay on the path man you might uh this
may have happened at the job you may
have did something to lose the job but
it's another way you know you can get
another job when I went back to the
neighborhood it's like nah you can come
over here with us we get some money over
this way me and my friends now we said
we was each other father when we was
growing up because none of us had a
father in the home so we kind of helped
raise each other and I failed and went
back to the people that I knew and that
was that then once I got in there I was
like I want to be the person that when
somebody that don't have a father come
back over and they need somebody to talk
to I need to tell them to do something
different than what they told me to do
and that's where all this stuff that
started coming together in my head and
that's why I was like nah I need to I
need to get the fathers because I think
that's the thing that's really missing
and when I was talking to my friend all
the time and he was coaching a middle
school basketball and he was telling me
like man last year
only one day it came to the school to
the game and he coaching boys and he
like only one day came to the games and
it clicked like that's what's missing I
became incarcerated in 2009 and up to
that point I had kind of uh vague
relationship with my daughter me not
being involved with my daughter as much
as I should and me seeing the lack of
fathers in my community I just started
researching thinking about it praying
about it and got on the typewriter one
day a manual typewriter and just typed
up this program called fathers and I got
out of prison in 2014 and once I got
home I just put my feet on the ground
and just went at it just started
reaching out to different fathers I made
a social media page on Facebook father's
organization and I started just reaching
out to different guys and telling them
what I was trying to do and like share
some kids is you and your kids on the
page and let's show the show the guys in
our community that we are needed and
because it's a stereotype like black
father's not involved with their kids so
I'm like let's show them the other side
of it let's show them up that we are in
our kids lives now they start posting
these pictures on there so I started
giving out like a father of the month
award
[Music]
the black community is that it's down 88
from two parent homes since 1960 and you
can easily contribute the crime here to
the lack of two pair of homes it's just
go hand in hand when both parents not
girl
is more likely for it to be a
dysfunctional community and that's what
I was seeing I just kept noticing that a
lot of the people that's getting in
trouble a lot of people that's going
down the wrong path they don't have
their father there but I started doing
like these events like come to the event
we're gonna have to stop the Riley's
event but
what I was doing was just getting the
fathers there so I can share with them
like man we got to be in these kids
lives we got to show them the stuff that
we didn't see the people we didn't have
nobody to guide us so we need to show
them the other way what if we are there
for them whatever sometimes when they're
having a bad day they do have somebody
to talk to they don't have to go and
click over the gang or something like
that they got their mother and father
there so that was my motivation just to
see the change I was trying to be the
change I wanted to see
now it's not a lot for the kids to do
here so they just really getting
involved in the wrong things a lot of
gun violence a lot of gun violence a lot
of hybrid gangs but when I was growing
up it was like you got cribs Bloods Vice
Lords Gangster Disciples and they had
these rules that they all went by
and it kind of
it didn't keep them from doing bad
things but it kind of kept them in line
in that game now the young guys don't
want to follow those rules even so they
make up hybrid games it's like
all is like people from each one of the
gangs coming together to make up their
own game so they don't have to follow
the rules of the people that's moved up
in those games or whatever so and this
a big problem there's no structure
that's that's contributing to a lot of
the crime here and then the social media
also then the lack of things to do the
lack of programs to get involved with
positive
it all kind of goes together and
contributes to what's going on as far as
violence go even though we're down like
four percent from last year it's still a
lie there's like over 340 homicides here
last year so that's a lot that was like
a record when you got a community it's
predominantly black
from their perspective I think the black
man is missing
me
so my thing is I got to show you how to
be there how to be how to play your role
because everybody got a role to play in
the family structure so my thing is I'm
gonna give the example of how to play
that role no matter how hard it is for
me I'm a stay married I'm gonna stay
involved with my kids I'm a state uh
recognizing guys who are involved with
their kids because sometimes we just
need a little recognition like to keep
going and a couple of the guys that I've
had come through the organization
actually got custody of the kids now and
the kids doing good
just walking up with people on the
street they like me you the guy they got
the father's organization like yeah like
man keep doing what you're doing because
you happy it's just more it's just
motivation it's like uh versus the
energy like man I know it's from coming
from just me typing it up on the
typewriter and saying something about it
what I typed up actually changed
somebody's life
I don't even have no words to explain it
and just did
acknowledgment that it's kind of working
even though it's it's a process
just those few little
people that that's
been successful doing it
you got to keep going one thing I think
people uh definitely should know is that
Memphis is a great place
it's actually a great place it's a lot
of beautiful things here it's not bad
people here just the circumstances that
they think uh make them do certain
things
what people being the worst communities
got the most beautiful people in there
but they just don't have the knowledge
of how to manifest the beauty